talking about the individual one of the
things that i see holding people back is
comfort so it's easy to get life to a
stage where it's not that bad
but it's not that good either at least
when you have a full-on breakdown
there's only one way to go right you're
only going to go up from there but i
think it's possible to wallow for yours
in a just about passable life right
sedated by comfort and i see this
temptation in myself as well to give up
the good for the great what would you
say to people who are trying to escape
this curse of mediocrity
well if you're satisfied with it in some
fundamental sense i mean there's there's
something to be said i suppose for
walling off a private space for yourself
if you can maintain it and
detaching yourself to some degree from
the troubles of the world and
maintaining your own little private
garden
the problem with that is the snakes tend
to seep in from the outside right it's
it's pretty difficult to wall yourself
off in any real sense from the concerns
of the world
so it isn't clear to me that that's a
viable solution
it also means that you might justify to
yourself lack of civic engagement you
know i shouldn't go to church i
shouldn't take part in the political
process because it's also corrupt i
should hide myself from
all the annoying
noise that's generated constantly on the
media front i have some sympathy for
that viewpoint but
i don't believe it's really possible
because
you can't have
you can't have a walled garden
independent of independently of the
health of the broader society it's just
not possible maybe you can have it for a
very short period of time but
so
but if you're if you're comfortable with
what you have and that it's gin it's
genuine comfort then i think hey but
generally it's not i think for the most
part it's it's people that have become
sedated you know they've forgotten their
dreams but they've forgotten that
they've forgotten them pink floyd's
comfortably numb is about this right
they've become comfortably numb
i think most people i have this friend
and this this story really hit me
so um during the pandemic
running a podcast i was able to have the
thing that i feel i'm good at my out
artistic pursuit and outlet that was
available for me to continue it was
actually increased because i didn't have
other stuff to do
and i have a friend that's a barber and
he got a job at a supermarket barber's
shut down for a long period of time he
got a job at a supermarket stacking
shelves overnight and i asked him i was
like man how are you how are you finding
the new job this is a big a big change
he's like do you know what it is i
actually don't mind the work i mean the
people that i work with
but man i miss being good at something
right right right well dude that hit me
yeah so hard right i missed being good
at something yeah yeah well people need
the opportunity
to be good at something it so then you
might ask yourself well what's the best
antidote to the discomfort of life and
you might say
well it's comfort
and
i suppose that's what you
act out when you swaddle a baby
but a better antidote is something like
adventure to excellence
and
that's far better antidote to suffering
than the mere absence of suffering
so
not to say that the mere absence of
suffering that's not nothing you know
stepping out of that
sedation from comforts difficult though
especially if you've become routine eyes
to it yeah well that's the difficult
difficulty of maturity you know the
freudians said very wisely that the good
mother necessarily fails
it means she stops providing the comfort
that insulates people against the need
for adventure i heard you say recently
that um
a mother's ability to let her child go
out into the world knowing that they're
still vulnerable and that it's now down
to them and the world to look after them
that's one of the bravest things it's
the female crucifixion
so and that's exemplified best in well
the best
portrayal of that i've seen is
michelangelo's pieda
now it's it's a statue of mary
uh and she has christ's body on her as
an adult on her lap and he's broken and
destroyed and you know she's displaying
that
and that's
that's the bravery of a mother to
allow that to happen but not only that
to to facilitate it
facilitate it so what about where you go
kid where you go way go
well why it's dangerous out there it's
like yeah no kidding
it's more dangerous here if you stay
with me
by a lot
so you might lose your body out there in
the world but if you stay here you lose
your soul
how do you see that as an individual
let's say that there isn't the mother
there that's pushing you along
well you know one of the things jung
carl jung
was very interested in the eatable
complex and that's basically that
overprotective maternal
and he
he criticized freud
for presuming that it was
really something the mother did
he said it's more relational than that
first of all it would be something the
father would allow to happen assuming
there was a father around so let's not
forget about the paternal contribution
to allowing that to occur
because in some sense it's the father's
role to
serve as the antithesis of that maternal
overprotection so a woman is extremely
bonded with her infant say between zero
and nine months and the infant is
utterly helpless
and so
complete compassion and the provision of
comfort is the only job that matters and
that's really the case
and then the woman has to switch gears
to some degree the mother has to switch
gears as the child starts to become
more
more mobile fundamentally and more
independent she has to let go of the
infant which is a real grieving process
and
she has to start to facilitate this
movement towards independence but that's
a hard shift and so partly the role of
the father
in that is to be an advocate for the
child's independence and to
comfort the mother to let her know that
that degree of security provision is no
longer necessary but also to
act as an advocate for the child's
outgoing
uh
outgoing desire
and so so it's the edible situation is
not only the mother it's also say the
weak father but then it's also the child
so you can imagine because
young
belief that these
negotiated agreements were
were relational so you know you're
six
you're in grade one
maybe you're feeling a little ill
maybe you're not
maybe you're playing with being a little
ill and maybe you're playing with
exaggerating how ill you are and your
mom comes downstairs and says
you know you've got a test today at
school maybe you haven't quite prepared
for it maybe you know you should have
and
she says but you know you you seem to
have a tummy ache
maybe you're too sick to go to school
and the kid thinks
maybe i could just stay home and
you know mom could tuck me in and i
wouldn't have to take that test and
i wouldn't have to confront the world
and he says yeah
yeah my stomach really hurts and
and away we go
and the child has made a choice
and you think well that's and that's a
catastrophic choice and you think well
children shouldn't be held accountable
for choices they make at that age it's
like
that child's soon going to be an adult
that's going to make very similar
decisions
the
choice has consequences and to be held
accountable for that is to recognize
purely that the choice has consequences
and that it is a choice now you know you
could say well 95 percent of the blame
is to be put on the mother and maybe
that's an overestimate i think it
probably is
but
the child could say mom you don't have
to worry about me i'm gonna get up and
go do this
and
that's choice
and that's the right choice
so these are always chicken and egg
problems obviously but
that that fleshes out the complexity of
the situation you know if you're if
you're being enticed down a pathological
road
you can accept or reject the invitation
now some people are better at enticing
and some people enforce it more harshly
and you know there's all sorts of
individual variability in situations
like this but
just because you're offered debate
doesn't necessarily mean that you have
to take it
so and i'm not a determinist i do
believe that people have free will
whatever that means
that's a murky subject and it gets
complicated the more you look at it but
whatever it's still a good shorthand way
of describing the fact that we seem to
be cursed with responsibility for our
own destiny at least to some degree
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace